welcome to this video playing arum it'sa
Armetta from from Spain with this let's
check Sergio s premier arm Wow there are
I am bound ok so the NIMS oh and let's
see can I do something about this this
tree care and I don't know I just about
200 points in the last couple of games
really not not really great yeah let's
see maybe the same ish can come to the
rescue played it with Bishop d7 yeah
it's it's something that black can play
of course but very often black will
return to Bishop a six ideas later
anyway um for here yeah i think still f4
and f5 it's a bit different with the
bishop on Bassam
interesting
yeah I can play Knight g3 here maybe
takes Knight takes not sure many ways to
play I can also take a five this is
trying to provoke yeah exactly g6 not
that it is necessarily bad it's just
looks that might help me ok let's
continue putting pressure on c5 yeah
black very often can just ignore this
and play move like 96 on Bishop a six so
maybe one of those cases
hmm John he has many many ideas 96 is
something that I would investigate for
sure like DC 594 can be interesting the
oxy 8's are also moves that looks at the
sea porn ok so d5 is this possible here
yeah let's let's do this it's a risky of
course but ok this is the Samish f-in I
takes ed CD ok is not doing any of that
just focused on the sea for porn
understandable so I could I could cover
it for a moment with Queenie to
yeah why not why not yeah this this is
this is of course possible but here i
have e 5d6 this this type of porn
sacrifice at least i have that ok I'm
going for it I is also in this pin so
it's a very very strange configuration
here should be six my different iced is
taking on g3 yeah that that's very bad
okay you have the difference with other
two other positions with this pawn wedge
on d65 is that the rare opens at night
on g7 and this is not the case here so
it does not have this incarcerated night
meaning that this is pretty much just a
pawn there are some very little to no
compensation to it poor how do I get
some play for this here not very
successful yeah talk about a bad run
that's it's really sweetie we add this
very this is kind of if it rains it
pours now you play one bad game you play
to your play three you play five it's
really strange okay he's ignoring this
my age five move of course it's not a
big threat or anything but it could have
easily stopped anything with age five
Jack yeah and he just marches the pawns
maybe you look f3 g3 something night she
won f3 mmm it's a very little hope the
pawns are really quick
yeah it's still a lot looking like like
I have anything really not even 95 it's
not especially dangerous threat no but
he is somehow reacting to it I take it
95 people take take the F porn this is
not good maybe I can go here here and
then 95 this this might be might be
something and I also threaten h6 rook
moves Rock g6 that's in fact nice maybe
something that you can really overlooked
and so it's not one of the most
brilliant traps ever but could be a
could be interesting
okay maybe this isn't so clear really
well that that's not this position is
not clear i also have now Queenie seven
this looks actually good for what he
cannot take the pawn and this is really
bad news if the porn is staying on the
board he will have problems definitely
okay the night will come in for coming
to play how do i do a play now night g
and I will climb are now remove the the
H pawn and it's not clear what this
really has accomplished queen e 795 he
has got he's got this coming Queen age
six maybe still 93 then I g5 night
everyone whom amazing the night here is
giving him enormous play yeah this is a
temple very important my oh so then
Knight f6 Queen f6 is coming take it 95
or is this how bad is this check really
I don't know
check this check i had overlooked great
check check check check wawa and press
the bunny with four seconds haha I
cannot win a game at the moment I mean
okay I was lost of course in the in the
middle of the game but here of course
white is totally winning but I didn't
see you when I really didn't see it 95
is right no dashes it also right and no
Queen g5s winning Knight to Queen g 5y
exactly a queen age 6 is so so dangerous
ok now i can just sacrifice and play
here and I'm safe yeah ok this is very
easy when actually Queen age 8 95 and
something like that was was it was clear
that something like that is the right
solution but I I played it I played it
wrong now look AAA twins I have no no
Madame Chiang amazing here each four
wins yeah I have no mating threats no
direct mating threat yeah well of course
I mean this is I was totally lost here
but you allowed some some very serious
counter play and this is a very clearly
lost yeah I cannot win a game at the
moment terrible okay thanks for watching